ok cyprien tu es allé beaucoup trop loin
de la chance après réflexion moi et ma
communauté on a décidé de répondre par
contre je vais pas mettre tombe vénère
yvon flipper je mette un truc qui leur
parle
son sens comme une merde c'était un tube
si tu étais pas dessus ternes adultes
qui parle de trucs de jeunes pour faire
des bulles comme facebook où on s'en bat
les couilles de thouars j'suis plus de
tout ego métrage suit en filmant mais
toi tu fait peine à voir que tu
t'habilles comme un comptable je suis
passé devant une maison de retraite à
temps pour le scrabble à des perruques
imitait des gens c'est juste pas marre
on a tous les deux par les récoltes soit
1 les 26 ans il est rien twitter quotas
série audio personne n'a écouté était
beaucoup trop confuse pour un mec a
l'air de guadeloupe et on va pas se
mentir à ses prix un gaming a sauvé par
mois pour exister terrain je suis vanné
le million d'abonnés était trop pour un
philosophe sa prochaine vidéo ce sera
légitime de preuve même les enfants nos
enfants trouveront ça nul à chier tu as
toujours pas permis est celle costumes
on l'a gagné
twizy vidéo pour monde vu depuis que tu
es sur ma porte
ce clash ton arrivée tu donnes tout mais
qui force la lâcheté du freeroll à
dépenser tout et sentiers mais ça me
rapporte de l'argent même si l'intérim
ces coquillages échoué que personne ne
veut la masse et je suis bigorneau style
et que tout le monde va s'arracher tu
veux représenter net mais tu viens de la
télé je te laisse le mot de la fin
n'oublie pas ta bonne et bonjour c'est
cyprien revenir sur l'épisode des anges
de la télé réalité
[Musique]